الحادثه على الحدود مع مصر خطيره وقاسيه
واستثنائيه وسنتابعها حتى النهايه
اخبر العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
مرحبا بكم بعد مقتل ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين
برصاص مجدد مصري
بالخطيره ويؤكد انه ينتظر تحقيقا مشتركا
وجديا مع مصر وتحقيق اولي للجيش
الاسرائيلي يكشف ان المنفذ خطط لمسار
تسلله وقطع مسافه طويله لفتح معبر الطوارئ
قبل ان يجتاز الحدود ويستهدف الجنود
الاسبوع الثامن من القتال قصف جوي ومدفعي
يهز الخرطوم مع توسع رقعه المعارك بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
مناطق عده بالعاصمه في حين دعت كل من
الرياض واشنطن الطرفين الى اتفاق جديد
لوقف اطلاق النار وتنفيذه بشكل فعال على
وقع توتر صيني امريكي متزايد البنتاغون
يتهم سفينه حربيه صينيه بالقيام بمناوره
امنه قربه مدمره امريكيه في مضيق تايوان
ويندد بما وصفها بالانشطه الخطره
والاستفزازيه للجيش الصيني ووزير الدفاع
الصيني يحذر من انشاء تحالفات شبيهه
النيتو في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهاتف ريال
مدريد يعلن رحيل قائده كريم بنزيما بعد
مسيره 14 عاما ساهم فيها بجداره في صناعه
العصر الذهبي للنادي الملكي وسيكون الوداع
الاخير له في حفل جماهيري الثلاثاء المقبل
في حين توصل نادي الاتحاد السعودي الى
اتفاق لضم بنزيما لموسمين في صفقه وصفت
بالقياسيه الى اللقاء